ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนะเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
อ่ะเดี๋ยวครูหญิงขอ Share  screen ก่อนนะ
คะครูเอ๋โอนค่ะหาไม่เจอนะคะถ้าเจอแดดแล้ว
[เพลง]
วันนี้วันอะไรคะคุย
วันนี้วันอะไรคะครูเอ๋สีเขียววันพุธค่ะ
เพราะว่าครูเอ๋ชอบและชอบพูดถึงก็เลยถาม
วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะเมื่อวานวันที่ 7
นะวันนี้วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8
วันที่ 8 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนค่ะ
ปีพตอะไรเนื้อหา
2465 ปีคศอะไรคะ
ค่ะเจ็บเจ็บนะคะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูเอ๋
ดูก่อนนะคะตอนนี้มีลา
03:53 นาทีวีมีเสียงดังอีกไม่มีใครทำ
อะไรกับตัวเองเนี่ย
03:53 นาทีตอนบ่ายนะคะใจค่ะตอนบ่ายน้อ by
3 แล้ว
เย้
ไม่ร้อนใส่ค่ะไม่ร้อนครูเอ๋คะอะไรคะเรียก
ทำไมมีคำถามอีกแล้ว
ถ้าไม่ตอบได้ไหมไม่ได้
ขอคำถามครูเอ๋รู้ไหมคะ
50 นะรู้นะคะเพราะถามครูเอ๋เลยค่ะครูเอ๋
อ้อยคุยเกมเป็นผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะ
คิดว่าอ้าว Bag ที่ผมยาวไงพี่ก็คิดผู้
หญิงนะคะเพราะผู้หญิงผู้หญิง a เป็นผู้
หญิงเนี่ยคุณเอ๋โหสวยไหม
ชอบไปเที่ยวดู a สวยอยากสวย
โอเควันนี้ชอบได้ค่ะถ้าไม่ชอบผู้หญิงก็
แบบคุยกับขี้โมโหแหละใช่ค่ะ
เพจ Shock สวยก่อนนะคะเราเบรคนิดนึงผู้
หญิงปิดหูทำไมคะ
นักเรียนจริงๆครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ชอบสวยคู๋ชอบดู
มีคนสวย
ชอบชอบดูครูหญิงนะคะขี้โม้
เกินไปนักเรียนเรียนแล้วอ่ะไม่ชอบสวยขอ
โทษตอนนี้เนี่ย
2000 อีกกี่โมงโหผู้หญิงแล้วสัตว์นี้นะ
คะ 2022 นะคะครูเอ๋เนี่ยอายุ 68 แล้ว
กูเอ๋
สวย
เดี๋ยวไปก่อนเดี๋ยวก่อนไปก่อนแต่เวลาครู
หญิงนักเรียนหาจริงๆกูเองไม่ใช่ 68 นะไม่
อ่าใช่ค่ะดูหน้าครูเอ๋เนี่ยหน้าครูเอ๋
เนี่ยไม่ใช่ 68 หน้าคู๋เหมือนสอบ
38 น่ารักครูหญิงน่ารักเธออีกนะคะแม่คุณ
หน้าคู่หญิงและก็เหมือน 15 หัวหน้ากูหญิง
เหมือน 38
par38 กดนะยัง 38 โหน้าผู้หญิงก็เหมือน
15 ครูเอ๋รู้ไหมทำไมหน้านะถ้าไม่ต้อง
ขนาดนั้นเลยทำไมหน้าครูหญิงเหมือนอายุ 15
ไม่รู้ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงกับครูเอ๋อยู่อยู่บ้านคนละหลังครู
หญิงทำยังไงคะหน้าเหมือน 15
รู้ตัวเองทำไมหน้าเหมือน 38 ต่อ
ทำไมทำไมตูมดี
ไม่ได้สิคะครูเอ๋เอ๋ไม่เป็นไรวันนี้เนี่ย
ครูหญิงจะมาบอกครูเอ๋
ให้ทำยังไงหน้า
เด็กๆผิว
สวยๆผม
สวยๆผู้หญิงรู้ด้วยหรอคะรู้ขลุ่ยเป็นทุก
ปีนี้ครูเอ๋แล้วบอกชอบสวยแต่ครูเอ๋ไม่ทำ
ครูหญิงทำผู้หญิงรู้ผู้หญิงต้องสอนครูเอ๋
นะคะเพราะว่าบางนักเรียนมากรุงเทพแล้ว
เดินสวนกับครูเอ๋เอ๋นักเรียนจะไม่รู้จัก
นะใช้ค่ะเพราะว่าครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงไม่มีแล้ว
เพราะว่าใส่แมสนะคะใส่หน้ากากหน้ากาก
ทำยังไงคะถ้าเราอยากจะสวยหรือว่าถ้านัก
เรียนนักเรียนผู้ชายค่ะนักเรียนผู้ชายก็
อยากหล่อหรอ
อยากผิวดีอ่ะอ่ะ
ก็พูดง่ายๆผู้ชายผู้หญิงเหมือนกันก็อยาก
ดูดีไง
เวลามีคนเดินมาแล้วมองเห็นแล้วโอ้
หล่อ
ผมสวยๆหอมนะคะนี่เลยค่ะเอ๋
อะไรอย่างแรกที่ครูหญิงทำ
ไม่ใช่ทุกวันน้องผู้หญิงทำเนี่ยวันพุธไม่
ใช่ผู้หญิงขาคุยดูไม่ได้เดี๋ยวเซ็กซี่วัน
พุธกับวันศุกร์เนี่ยผู้หญิงทำจับดาละ 2
ครั้งหรอคะ
ค่ะครูเอ๋แล้วใช้เวลา 1 ครั้งเนี่ยใช้
เวลานานเท่าไหร่ประมาณ
ผู้หญิงนะ
30 นาทีค่ะครูเอ๋ 30 นาทีหรอบ่
ต้องพิมพ์ก็มีไหมเราเห็นก็ไม่รู้ว่าเขาทำ
เท่าไหร่
น่าจะ 3 ชั่วโมงไม่ผู้หญิงพอแล้ว 30 นาที
ทุกวันไงทำบ่อยๆทำอะไรแม่สาวอาบน้ำไม่ใช่
อาบน้ำค่ะ 1 ผู้หญิงอันนี้ผู้หญิงคนนี้
เนี่ยเขานอนอยู่ในอ่างอันนี้คืออ่างอ่าง
kuai ก็มีฟองใจมีฟองก็แช่น้ำอุ่น
โอเค 30 นาทีเข้าใจได้สบู่ไม่ฟองใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะก็มีอันนี้ให้กูเองก็มีบาธบอมเห็น
รู้จักบาสบอมไหมค่ะไม่รู้จักในไม่เคยทำ
มัน
จะผู้หญิงเปิดให้ดูแล้วกันนะคะคู๋ไม่รู้
จักแต่คู่เห็นในเนี่ยมีดอกกุหลาบเนี่ยแต่
ใช่อ๋อต้องใส่ดอกกุหลาบให้หอมๆหลายใส่อัน
นี้ด้วยคะอันนี้เรียกว่าบาสบอมใส่ลงไปแต่
มันก็จะ
เป็นน้ำหอม
ๆๆๆกูเองไม่รู้หรอกว่าเรียกว่าอะไรแต่กู
เอกเคยใช้
ใช่ไหมคุยเขาเรียกบาสบองน้ำเนี่ยก็ประมาณ
อัน
50 ร้อนไปไหมคะ
ต้มยำเหรอคะคุยมันก็ไม่รู้
ตีสิบพอโอเคฟิล์ม
30 นาทีถึง
40 องศา
เซลเซียส 8 ราคานามนี่ไงน้ำอุ่นปิดก็นอน
แช่น้ำอุ่นแล้วก็มีหนังสือหนังสือก็กลับ
หัวแล้วก็อ่านหนังสือ
เอาไว้อ่านการ์ตูนนะคะๆค่ะผิวก็จะนิ่มนี่
มาขอ
น้ำหอมครูเอ๋ทำยังไม่ขาดจะนอนแช่ก่อนอ๋อ
อ๋อคุยกับถามอะไรครูเอกค่ะเขวเคยทำไหมคะ
อ่าอาเคยแต่ไม่มีไม่มีฟองอันนี้
[เพลง]
ครูเอ๋จากแช่แบบนี้ค่ะครูหญิงนะคะเอาสี
อะไรดีนะคะสีเขียวและกันของตัวเองพรุ่ง
นี้นะคะเป็นแบบนี้
หาแล้วก็มีน้ำร้อนโง่ไม่รู้อะไร
ฉีกแล้วก็ใส่
แต่ก็จะป้อมๆ
บาสบอมแล้วน่ะค่ะแล้วก็ของหอมๆให้ปิด
บัญชีเป็นราเวนเดอร์
เป็นมะนาวเป็นอะไรไม่รู้แล้วก็นอนนะแน่
นอนแช่นอนแช่หนูอันนี้คู่เอกเคยทำรู้เห
ล็งก็กูเอกเคยแช่อันนี้ค่ะครูหญิงเป็นให้
อะไรเป็นน้ำที่มา
ออนเซนออนเซ็นน้ำพุแช่แค่ใช้เวลาเท่าไหร่
ไม่แช่นานเท่าไหร่ติด 5 นาทีพอตา 15 นาที
เดี๋ยวเหี่ยวเนาะไม่ใช่มันร้อน
15 นาทีนักเรียน 15 นาทีร้อนแล้วนะคะ
แล้วก็อันนี้ล่ะมาคุยแช่นี้ล่ะคะแช่น้ำ
อุ่นที่มีหอมๆแช่กี่นาทีเอกก็ประมาณ 15-20
นาทีมีใช่ไหมนี่ผู้หญิงครึ่งชั่วโมงนะคะ
ใส่ค่ะเพราะว่าอ่านการ์ตูนขอจบก็พอดีก็
เคยแช่เหมือนกันแต่กูเองไม่ชัดไม่ชอบอยู่
เฉยๆนานๆไม่ใช่
ถ้าครูเอ๋เอกเคยแช่แล้วผู้หญิงเนี่ยนอก
จากแช่เนี่ยผิวตัวสวยใช่ไหมคะเดี๋ยวต้อง
หน้าด้วยแค่นะคะ
ก็จะได้หน้าสวยผู้หญิงบอกว่าผิวสวยนะ 08
แพร่ลงไปมายแค่น้ำอุ่นแหละครูหญิงทำ 2
วันแต่ว่าน้าเนี่ยคุยทำทุกวันวันจันทร์
วันอังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์วัน
เสาร์วันอาทิตย์ทุกวันทำอะไรหนิงอาบน้ำ
เสร็จแปรงฟันเสร็จแล้วก็ทำค่ะทำอะไรคะ
ไม่ใช่อันนี้ค่ะขอโทษเขาทำผิดเลี้ยงผิด
มาร์คหน้าค่ะครูเอ๋มาร์คหน้าเนี่ยมีแตง
กวาด้วยนะน่ะจ่ายใส่แตงกวานี้มาตานะคะแต่
ว่ามากหน้าเห็นไหมมีสีเขียวๆแล้วก็ทาที่
ไม่น่ะใช้อะไรอ่ะอันนี้เขาน่าจะใช้เป็น
ใครอะไรอ่ะโคลนหรอโคลนมาร์คหน้า
งาน
กูเองไม่ทำอ่ะผู้หญิงแต่ว่ากูหญิงก็จะไม่
มีอันนี้ด้วยนะพี่เอ๋มันไม่ได้มีแค่ครนมี
อะไรอีกนี่ไงอันนี้เนี่ยแบบนี้อีกนี้แล้ว
ที่ตู้เย็นให้นะคะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็มีใน
ตู้เย็นกูเองไงออมีแผ่นมาร์คหน้าๆทรายกู
any แผ่นมาร์คหน้าเหรอคะ 3 ปีแล้วอยู่ใน
ตู้เย็นคุยไม่ได้แล้วค่อยแล้วหน้าคันไหม
ค่ะทิ้งคือครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ใช้มีมีนักเรียน
ให้มาบอกว่าครูเอ๋พี่มาร์คหน้าแล้วหน้า
สวยอันนี้ใส่ตู้เย็นนะครูเอกก็เลยใส่ตู้
เย็นแล้วก็ลืมผู้เองดีนะมาร์คหน้าแล้ว
หน้าเนี่ยนิ่มๆสวย
ตีๆแทนได้ไหมได้ครูเอ๋เนี่ยหน้าเล็กๆ
แผ่นมาร์คหน้าเนี่ยโอเคครูหญิงเนี่ยต้อง
ดึงดึงได้ปิดร้อนแสง
คือแผ่นมาร์คได้นะมันเลยไปถึงหูค่ะผู้
หญิงกูเอ๋แล้ว
แผนมากนะมันใหญ่อยู่การทำไมใหญ่วะ
ครูหญิงก็คิดทำไมแผ่นมาร์คหน้าจออันเล็ก
มากผู้หญิงได้แค่นี้ของกูเองดึง
จมูกมันไม่แก่เลยมาอยู่ที่นี่จมูกผู้หญิง
ก็ได้แค่นี้ค่ะเสื้อแดงปิดจมูกด้วยคุณ
ต้องดึงดึงแผ่นมาร์คหน้ามันดูนะคะนี่อยู่
ใกล้ๆเหมือนกันนะคะแต่หน้ากูเองจะน่าจะ
ยาวหน้าผู้หญิงหน้ากู้หญิงจะออกข้างๆค่ะ
ทรายก็มากนะหา
คู๋
เคยทำเมื่อก็
เมื่อก่อนต่อแต่ตอนนี้ไม่มาคุยหญิงเข้าใจ
นะคะเพราะว่าในตู้เย็น 3 ปีแล้วต้องทิ้ง
ใช่ไหมหญิงค่ะงูใช้ไม่ได้เหรอไม่ได้
เดี๋ยวขั้นน่าเอามามากแขนแทนได้ไหมได้ค่ะ
ได้อยู่
ผิวสวยแล้วหน้าสวยแล้วก็ต้องผมผมสวยต้อง
ทำผมด้วยนะคะนายค่ะย้อนกลับขึ้นมาสวยแล้ว
นี่ไงก็ต้อง
ถ้าผมค่ะครูเอ๋
ไม่ใช่มีแชมพูแล้วก็สระเสร็จแล้วได้ไหม
ไม่ได้จะเสร็จก็ต้องหมักผมด้วย
หงอมาก่อนบักผมทำยังไงคะนี่ไงครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็
จะมีน้ำผึ้งค่ะน้ำมันมะกอก
ว่านี่แหละจะมาใข้ว่านหางจระเข้หรือว่า
นี้ก็ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋อะไรอ่ะอันนี้อ่ะไม่ใช่
ใครอ่าไข่มาจากไหนคะไอ้นะหาไข่ไก่ไอ้ไก่
อะไรนะคะอีกรอบได้ไหมคะ
หือไข่เห็นไหม
ไข่แล้วก็ใส่ด้วยไม่ว่าให้ได้ไหมไข่ผู้
หญิงเนี่ยทำไมคะไข่ผู้หญิงสวยหรอคะ
เอกไม่ผู้อ่าโอเคค่ะไข่มันเป็นอย่างนี้
มั้ย
โอเคอ่าไข่สมัยแล้วก็
ต่อเอาไข่อะไรคะครูเอ๋ใครไก่นะไม่ไข่ขาว
หรือว่าไข่แดง
ไข่เน้ออออต้องแยกด้วยเหรอไม่ถูกไม่รู้
ไข่แดงแกงไข่แดงเวลาที่เราตอบไข่ออกมา
โอเคตอบไข่ออกมาใช่ไหมเกิดอ่ะ
ตอบไข่ออกมาก็จะมี
มีไข่ข้างในตรงเนี้ย
เสียง nam มากตอนนี้นะคะนักเรียนขาไข่แดง
ค่ะอ้าเอาใส่แดงแล้วก็ผสมน้ำผึ้งน้ำมัน
มะกอกว่านายช่วยใช่ค่ะคะแล้วก็
คนแล้วก็เอาใส่ที่โพลผมแล้วก็
มากไว้ประมาณต้องมีอะไรคุมด้วยไหมผู้หญิง
ใต้ค่ะมีอะไรเนี่ย
ต้องมีหมวกสมัยแล้วก็คลุม
โอเคจ้า
แล้วก็
มากๆประมาณกี่นาทีครู S  10 นาทีพอไหมไม่
พอ
เท่าไหร่คะครึ่งชั่วโมงถึงหนึ่งก็
โห
30 นาทีถึง 1 ชั่วโมงใช่ไหมผมก็จะนิ่มมี
มาแล้วก็ไปสระผมแบบผมอีก 4 ครั้งจ่ายค่ะ
เพราะว่าไข่เหม็นนะคะมายรหาก็
หมักผมดีแล้วครูหญิงรู้ไหมหมักผมเสร็จ
แล้วใช้ไข่แดงไข่ขาวๆเอาไปทำอะไร
ให้ขาวเอาไปทำอะไรคะครูเอ๋เอาไปทำอาหาร
ไม่ใช่
เอาไปทำอะไรผู้หญิงก็มีทิชชู่สิคะเป็น
ทิชชู่แล้วทิสชู่ทำอะไรคะพี่ชูก็ได้สำลี
ก็ได้สำลีสำลีสำลีตอนพี่ทุกข์ที่มันโต๊ะ
เลยค่ะเหมือนกูเอ๋กูเองไม่กล้าให้ดูโต๊ะ
ค่ะรกมากมีสำลีค่ะสำลี
สำลีหรือทิชชู่โอเคแล้วก็ผู้หญิงหมักผม
ใช่ไหมที่นี่ผมรอก็อาจจะนอนนะนอนก็เอา
ทิชชูนะแปะหรือสำลีแปะที่ไข่ขาว
ที่ขาวทำอะไรแล้วครูหญิงก็เอามาวาง
แม่นา
วางที่หน้าทำไมหน้าสวยหรอมาร์คหน้าเหรอคะ
เฮ้ยๆแล้วก็วางที่จมูกอย่างเงี้ย
หือเหมือนๆมาร์คหน้าโอโห้
ก็เงินมากๆเลยแต่ต้องรอให้แค่ข้างเลยนะ
ก็มาร์กเสร็จมาร์คไข่ขาวแล้วครูหญิงก็รอ 1
ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมงเปิดพัดลมด้วยนะผู้หญิง
มีพันธุ์ลม
พัดลมน่ะลมเป่าให้หน้าแห้งเหรอคะมีมีอัน
นี้ใช่ไหมคะมีมามาร์คไข่ขาวที่นี่
พ่อแห้งนะคะแพรกแว่นตาไม่ต้องใส่แล้วก็
ไม่ใส่แห้งเสร็จที่นี่ป๊อกๆแข็งๆๆอ้าว
แล้วทำอะไรต่อผู้หญิงก็ดึงข้างล่างนะข้าง
บนไม่ได้นะข้างล่างค่ะแกะต้องถึงตรงนี้นะ
คะ
ให้ดึงแล้วก็กด a ไม่เจ็บหรอ
หน้าสวยไม่เอาค่ะ
สิวสิวที่เนี่ยที่นี่จะมีสิวมันจะดอกรู้
กู
จะสวยกว่าผู้หญิงโอเคโอเคถ้าครูหญิงหมัก
ผมถึงจะได้มาร์คหน้าไปด้วยได้แต่เจ็บค่ะ
เออต้องชอบเจ็บ
มันจะดึงป่าวอ่าแล้วครูหญิงจะเห็นเป็นแบบ
นี้อันนี้เป็นหน้าหน้าใช่มั้ยที่มาร์ค
ที่นี่จะมีสีเหลือง
อามิสิวใช่มั้ยสิวเสี้ยนที่จมูก
ก็จะหลุดออกมาหัวหน้าไงก็จะสวย
ออกๆคลิปนี้นักเรียนอยากจะตีครูไหมเนี่ย
คุณนาย
เอ๋ยังมีอีกนะคะนี่มากน่าไปแล้วใช่ไหมทำ
นี่ค่ะ
อะไรใครค่ะนวดหน้านะครับครูเอ๋
หน้าเนี่ยมันแบบอย่างนี้ไม่สวยต้องนวดหนู
คุณนั้นขึ้นเหรอค่ะใช่ค่ะนี่วัฒนาด้วยนะ
คะเนี่ยนะคะนวดว่าสิคะเราจะได้สวยไงครู
เอ๋
ไม่ๆๆนวดจะไม่ได้กินไอศครีมค่ะนวดหน้าม้า
ผู้หญิงนวดหน้าบ่อยๆไหมคะไม่ค่ะค่ะผู้
หญิงนวดหน้า 1 อะไรนะเค้าได้เลยคะ
ครั้งต่อ 1 สัปดาห์สัปดาห์ละครั้ง
คู๋ไม่ได้นวดเลย
ถ่ายค่ะก็จะได้สวยไงไม่ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋เพราะ
ว่ายังไม่หมดถึงจะบอกกูอีกว่าทำยังไงสวย
อีกเอาหรอกูยังไม่รู้เลยนวดยังไงนวดหน้า
แม่เดี๋ยวให้ครูเอ๋สอนวิดีโอต่อไปนวดหน้า
นะคะไม่ได้ไม่ไม่ได้อยู่ด้วยกัน
อ่ะนอกจากนวดหน้าแล้วเหนื่อยคือบอกว่า
แต่นี่ไม่ใช่มาร์คหน้านะครูเอ๋อันนี้อะไร
อ่ะอันนี้เนี่ยขัดหน้า
แล้วทำไมมีพู่กันเอาก็อันนี้เป็นสครับ
เมียคะคุณเอ๋สคราฟเอาพู่กันเนี่ย
ใช้อะไรตัดนะครับจุ่มสระครับแล้วก็ทายช้า
ใช่ไม่ได้ใช้มือก็ได้ค่ะ
นี่ไงเนี่ยสระครับใช่ไหมสระครับ
อันนี้มันไม่ใช่ไหมสักครับสมัย
ไทยทรายค่ะอันนี้ต้องอันนี้อาจจะอ่า 2
ครั้งต่อเดือน
หรือว่า 1 ครั้งบ่อยๆไหมดีอันนี้นานๆ 1
ครั้งตัว a เคยทำไม่เคยขัดหน้าเหรอคะ 10
ปีที่แล้ว
ครูเอก
สวยมั้ย
คุยทำเนี่ย
2012 นะคะนักเรียน 10 ปีที่แล้วไม่ได้
คุยตอนนี้เนี่ย
2022 แล้วออต้อง 30 วันหนึ่งครั้งสอง
ข้างๆฟรี 1 ครั้งไม่ได้หรอคะไม่ได้ค่ะไม่
ได้เคยต้องขัดขัดขัด
ที่ไหนคะอันนะคะอุ้ย
เขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะร้านขายลิฟท์ G ร้านขาย
ที่เขียนคิ้วบูทวัตสันมีค่า
a เคยขัด
10 ปีที่แล้วนะฟรี
อันนี้ไม่ฟรีใครต้องซื้อฟรีก็เลยนั้น
เอยากขัดฟรีครูเอกก็ใช้น้ำตาลเนี่ยเป็น
น้ำตาลนะหวานๆเนี่ยน้ำตาล
แล้วก็
น้ำตาลกับน้ำผึ้งหรือน้ำมันผสมกันแล้วก็
ขัดได้ไม่เจ็บหรอคะเด็กค่ะมันจะเจ็บนิด
หน่อยอ่าไม่เป็นไรครับ
ปาดขัดหน้าไม่สวยโอเคหนึ่งก็ถ้าผู้กวน
เจ็บก็ขัดตัวสมัยแต่นี่เป็นกาแฟนะคะเป็น
กาแฟที่มันจะมีแบบเป็นร้านกาแฟเดี๋ยวพี่
เอามาให้ดูที่บ้านมี
คุยก็มีแต่ไม่เคยใช้ฟรีมีกาแฟ
ทีเวลาที่ที่ที่ชงนะคะนักเรียนมีกาแฟแต่
เป็นกาแฟแล้วนะก็เอาน้ำหนักเป็นกาแฟแบบ
นี้กาแฟแบบ Love  The  A  Fast ให้ดูนะคะ
ผู้หญิงดีมันหมดอายุแล้วแล้วมีกับกาแฟผง
รหัส
กาแฟเป็นผงแล้วที่นี่ก็จะมีเป็นแบบนี้อา
ชีก็ได้อีกไปข้างในก็มีกาแฟเป็นผงนะคะนัก
เรียนแบบนี้ก็ได้ค่ะ
ที่ดื่มไปแล้วหรือเนื้อผงกาแฟเหลือผงอ่ะ
แล้วก็เอามาฉัตรซ้ายโอเคเซอร์มีเก็บถึง
นี้ก็ร้านกาแฟกินไม่ได้แล้วนะฮะ
หมดอายุแล้วพี่ดูแล้วกูเอง 2021 นะคะไม่
เป็นไรปีที่แล้วทรายมีอีกทั้งคู๋ตัวอัน
นี้ Scrubb เนาะอันนี้เนี่ยอาบน้ำมาร์ค
หน้าขัดหน้าเสร็จแล้วก่อนนอนก็ต้องทาครีม
ทาครีมริ่มกลางคืนชายค่ะครีมกลางคืนกลาง
วันก็ได้นะกูเอ๋กลางคืนก็ได้กลางวัน
ฟรีตอนกลางวันกับครีมตอนกลางคืนสายค่ะภาค
ก่อนนอนก็ทาครีมตอนกลางคืนนัดตื่นนอนมา
เกาะทาครีมกลางวันคุยถ้าครีมไหมคะมี
โลชั่นมอยซ์เจอไรเซอร์เดย์ครีมไนท์ครีม
และ
วิปครีมขัดที่มีคลิปครีมอร่อยค่ะ
ขอโทษนะคะพี่เอ๋ไม่มีครีมเลยค่ะน้องทา
ครีมค่ะถ้ามีโลชั่น ok  ok
ได้ๆค่ะ
ๆๆวิกมาเร็วๆเนี่ยผู้หญิงในผู้หญิงแหละ
บางครั้งเนี่ยทาครีมครีมที่ 1 เสร็จก็จะ
มีครีมกระปุกที่ 2 ทาในค่าโลชั่น
เป็นน้ำน้ำมากผู้หญิง 1 เหรอคะครูเอ๋เออ
กูแอบมีหนึ่ง
หมดแล้วแต่ว่ามีนักเรียนเห็นหน้าคุยอ่ะ
ไม่อดทนนักเรียนบอกโอเคมีครีมตัวนี้ให้พอ
ดีค่ะนี้ดีครีมยี่ห้อนี้ดีค่ะคุณเอ๋กู M
ไม่เคยใส่นี้นะคะอันนี้เป็นครั้งที่ 1 มี
ครีมชนิดครีมทาหน้าใช่ไหมกูเอ๋หน้าโอเค
ตัวโอเคแต่เขามองเห็นเป็นครีมเป็นโลชั่น
โลชั่นสิค่ะทาหน้าก็บอกขาหน้าแต่ว่าเก๋
ปกติก็จะใช้เป็นน้ำค่ะงั้นเดี๋ยวต้องทา
ครีมแล้วเราก็จะสวยโอเคมีครีมเดี๋ยวก่อน
ค่ะเดี๋ยวยังไม่ต้องทาอาบน้ำเสร็จค่ะอาบ
น้ำเสร็จก่อนนอนค่อยทาไม่ใช่ตอนนี้ค่ะครู
เอ๋อันนี้นักเรียนจะได้เห็นได้ค่ะคุยซะ
ถ้าเลยไม่ล้างหน้าเลย
เดี๋ยวคันทุกวันแล้วก็คุย
น้องอีกใครอีกทีอีกค่ะอ่าถ้าเป็นผู้ชาย
อันนี้ผู้ชายไม่อย่างเดียวหรอกแต่ผู้ชาย
ทาครีมก็ได้หานี้ผู้หญิงที่มีน้องผู้ชาย
ก็โกนหนวดใช่ไหมโกนหนวดชายนวดหน้าก็ได้
ได้นะผู้ชายดูคนอวดนะคะนี่เหมือนกันให้
ผู้ชายเขาก็โกนหนวดมีแฟชั่นนะเราจังเลย
ตายหล่อหล่อนะคะแล้วก็อาจจะผู้หญิงบางคน
อาจจะโกนขนขนขาหน้าแข้งไหมสายขนหน้าแข้ง
อ่ะนะคะโอนหน้าแข้ง
โอเคเดี๋ยวกูเองแต่โกนขนหน้าแข้งก่อนก็
ได้ไม่โกนก็ได้ครูหญิงไม่โกนนะคะพี่เอ๋
ไม่มี
เน็ตค่ะนี่ไงผู้หญิงไทยเนี่ยโกนขนรักแร้
และผู้หญิงไทยนะอ่าคุยแสร้งมีอะไรคะเว็ป
มีมีชาติขนรักแร้ผู้หญิงแถวหน้าอย่างนั้น
อีกไม่มีแล้วนะเอ้าพูดทำไมเนี่ย Top
Secret  Book ขอตั้งแต่รับคีโมไม่มีไม่
มีเลยไม่ขึ้น
ผู้หญิงเขาว่าเป็นบุคคลอีกตายแต่ว่าบางคน
ก็ก็โกนใช่ไหมโกนไม่มี
ทรายนิดหน่อยไม่ต้องโกรธนายแต่ตอนนี้สมัย
ตอนนี้น่ะปี
2022 แล้วผู้หญิงโกนโอเคไม่โกนโอเค
เดี๋ยวนี้เขาไม่ต้องโกนกูหญิงเขา
Wax ตากไข่ไก่นะคะไข่ไก่ไก่ไหวออก
เจ็บป่ะมี EOS มินิคให้เทา
ใช่เจ็บนิดหน่อยนะคะอ่ะอ่ะนี่ก็แต่งหน้า
ใช่ไหมเราก็สวยแต่งหน้านะคะผู้ที่ไหนพอ
เพราะคุยไม่แต่งนะคะ
อันนี้ค่ะทาเล็บ Great  Talent ถ้าไม่ทา
หรือว่าได้เนี่ยจะได้ยินว่าบางคนคนไทยพูด
ทำเล็บมั้ยว่าทั้งหมดเลยอ่ะไม่มีมีตะไบนะ
คะแล้วก็ตะไบเล็บ
[เพลง]
ไส้นี่นะตะไบเล็บแต่งหน้าแล้วผู้หญิง
หิวนะ
นี่กูเองเข้าใจนะทำไมในนี้สวยแล้วนะคิ้ว
ดูคิ้ว
เปลี่ยนก็ได้เปลี่ยนก็ได้
อ๋อครูเอ๋แต่งหน้าในซูมโอเคไหมผู้หญิงอะ
ดีขึ้นนิดนึงค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋สวยสวยสวยแต่
คิ้วข้างนี้ใหญ่อ่าข้างนี้เล็กทางนี้ใหญ่
นะคะไม่เข้ากันโอเคไหมคะนี้นะ
ไม่เท่ากันนะครับพี่เอ๋คิ้ว hue ไม่กูเอง
ไม่แต่งหน้าสวยกว่าค่ะโอเคเอาคิ้วออกนะมา
เอาคิวออกอ่ะแต่งหน้าเอาคิวออกอ่ะหาสวย
ค่ะ
สอนกับครูเรียมก็มีแม็กซ์มีหนวดสอนคุย
อิ๋งก็มีคิวไก่นี้ก็ทำเล็บนะคะแล้วก็อ่า
แต่ว่าบางคนอันนี่คาโรออนทำไมต้องทาโรออน
อ้าวบางทีเนี่ยจั๊กกะแร้เนี่ยหึมีกลิ่นก็
ทาโรออนก็
ของทรายทาโรออนแล้วก็
บ่ายคนก็ฉีดน้ำหอมไงคะผู้เหริเป็นน้ำหอม
ก็ฉีดน้ำหอมจะก็
หนาวถามผู้หญิงคะเออผู้หญิงจะสวยใช่ไหมคะ
เวลาผมแชมพูก็หอมใช่มั้ยใช่เวลาเลือกครีม
ที่หน้าขอมั้ยพร้อมขอมโลออนหอมไหมคะ
หอมผัดตัวเนี่ยขอมไหมคะ
หอมสบู่เจลอาบน้ำหอมไหมคะ
หอมน้ำหอมไหมคะงน้องกลิ่นเหมือนกันไหมคะ
ไม่เหมือน
เกินนั่นแหละ
ไม่กล้วยบางคนเขากลิ่นเหมือนกันอันนี้ขอ
หอมหน่อยๆก็แล้วหอมอ่อนๆ
ผม 1 กลิ่นรักแร้ 1 กลิ่นผิว 1 กลิ่นน้ำ
หอม 1 กลิ่นครูเอ๋เอ๋ได้กลิ่นเวียนหัวคู๋
คะเขาไม่ได้มีแค่น้ำหอมอันนี้เป็นน้ำหอม
ฉีดตัวใช่ไหมฉีดแขนที่ตัวเขามีน้ำหอมที่
ฉีดแต่ผมด้วยนะคะครูเอ๋
เขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะ miss  miss  hmong อ่า
ฉีดผมสำหรับฉีดผมให้ผมหอมมีเงินก็ผู้หญิง
ไทยชอบกินบาร์บีคิวบาร์บีคิวเนี่ยมีกลิ่น
ค่ะอย่าก็ฉีดผมกินบาบีคิวเสร็จ
บาร์บีคิว
ก็มีสเปรย์แล้วก็ฉีด
หอมกูเป็นผู้หญิงที่เหนื่อยเนาะใช่อะไร
ครูเอกเป็นผู้หญิงอายุ 54 ไม่ต้องหอมไม่
เป็นไรค่ะซูมนักเรียนไม่ได้กลิ่นไม่แปรง
ฟันนักเรียนก็ไม่ได้กลิ่นไม่สระผมนัก
เรียนก็ไม่ได้กลิ่นแต่นักเรียนดูเข้าใจ
ตายค่ะเดี๋ยวผมจะเดี๋ยวผมจะถ่ายอันนี้ก็
อีก 3 คนแล้วนะคะนักเรียนดูนะฮะสระแล้ว
ใช่ไหมคะจับแล้วสามวันที่แล้วเป็น
นะนี้ก็เป็นวิธีดูแลตัวเองใช่ไหมให้เรา
เนี่ยดูดีใช้ค่ะ
แล้วเหนื่อยเนาะกูเองก็คิดเหมือนกันเอา
ไม่ต้องทำทางหมดไงวันไหนมีเวลาทำไม่มี
เวลาก็นอนเยอะๆสวยค่ะบ้ายเพราะว่าถ้าจะทำ
ทุกๆอย่างโอ้ย 1 วันต้องใช้เวลาที่ห้อง
น้ำสระผมขัดแต่งหน้า 2-3 ชั่วโมง
ไม่ได้ก็วันไหนมีเวลาทำนะคะต้นวันนี้หมด
เวลาแล้วผู้หญิงจะไปตัดผมแล้วค่ะคุยแล้ว
แต่
ใจขาดอะวันนี้ไปก่อนนะโรงเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
ค่ะบ๊ายบาย